- But the other news, wait,
this is actually fantastic.
- What?
- I have thought you were
married this whole time.
(laughing)
(hands clap)
Like you're newly engaged and
I'm like, "Congratulations,"
but I was like, "What?"
Anytime you sent me videos
- Yeah.
- of, like, drinking
with your man
- Yeah.
- or like you're on vacation,
- first of all, I'm like,
"I want your life."
And then, like, I thought you
were married this whole time.
- Yes, you know what's funny?
- They were, like,
"Oh, she got engaged."
I was like, "To another person?"
Or, like, "Is she divorced?"
Like, "Why, what?"
- You know what?
Joel, I met Joel, like, randomly
at a book signing one day
like six years ago and it
was one of those crazy nights
that you're so happy you went out.
We started dating, and a few years in,
all I was thinking about was having kids
and I couldn't push it away.
And when I asked him
and I brought this up,
I said, "I can't push it away anymore."
I said, "I have to ask you
this important question."
I said, "Will you explore
adoption with me?"
And literally, without
blinking, without pausing,
he looked at me and he said, "Yes.
"Yes, yes."
- I love him.
- I already knew he loved me
- Yeah.
- that much,
so I kind of didn't care
about the married part.
I was like, "Okay, well we're
in love, we have two kids."
Like, "Who cares?"
It did matter to him, I think, a lot.
- Yeah.
- And one day we were at the beach,
and it was just the two of
us having a mom and dad trip,
and he started giving--
- I love mom and dad trips.
(audience laughs)
- We were having tequila
- Girl.
- and churros.
We were in Mexico.
- Girl.
- I was like, "Ah,
"I'm so happy."
- I'm like,
I love an adult trip.
- And he was kinda giving a little,
a little, like, love speech,
which he does sometimes,
like, "Let's talk about where we are,"
and I love when he does that.
And I was like, "Oh, that's so cute,"
and I had another tequila
and was, like, licking the.
(audience laughs)
And then he was like,
and he goes, "I really
have something important
"that I'd like to say."
I said, "Yes.
"I love all of your talks about love.
"Yes."
And I was buzzed.
- You're like slightly
hammered, yeah.
- I was so happy.
- You're like, "Yes, I love us."
- And then he kicked the chair out
and he got on a knee
- Oh.
and he was crying and I was
crying and I didn't even.
He goes, "Did you say yes?"
I said, "Did you ask?"
Like I couldn't, it was too
much, there was the ring.
But anyway, and in that moment,
I thought I'd feel like
I did the day before
'cause I already loved him,
but I had no idea how profound
- Yeah.
- saying something out loud is
like that.
- And telling other people.
There's something to that
- Yes.
- as well, 'cause I was like you.
Well first of all, my mom is still shocked
that I'm married and have children.
So I just didn't think
that was gonna happen,
but it's just one of those things
that, you know, didn't matter to me
as much as it mattered to my husband.
He had kids and he was, like,
- Yes.
- And he thought, "I don't know.
"I think it's important, you know."
And I was like, "Oh, I'm cool with that,"
and then he popped the question one day.
But once it does happen,
you're like, "Oh no, that is different."
- Yes.
- It's different
than just being together
and in love.
- I didn't--
- It's a really cool
declaration
- Yes.
- in front of everyone and, you know,
just a real, like, "Nah, hell
no, stay away from my man,"
you know?
(laughing)
- It's a nice thing, a ring.